[Music]
look closely
what do we all have in common
no matter what corner of the world you
live in you need food
water and money
half of every transaction involves money
in exchange for goods or services
stocks a loaf of bread illegal drugs
you gotta pay for it we spend much of
our lives chasing money to make a living
and accomplish our dreams but it's also
an instrument of destruction
some might say evil driving criminals to
lie
steal and even murder the existing
banking system extracts enormous value
from society
and it is parasitic in nature
money is a catalyst for the worst and
the best
of human endeavor before civilization
we created currency fuel for wars
the path to power champion
and enemy of innovation
money is so integral to our society and
our global economy
that its true nature remains a mystery
to most
this is the story of money perhaps the
end of money as we know it
no matter how fat your bank account or
how thin your wallet
to us it's all cold hard cash there are
some who want to kill it
get rid of it burn your dollars your
euros your yen
and transform every penny you have into
ones and zeroes
digital currency entrusted to the web
and computers spread across the planet
magic internet money it's called
cryptocurrency
bitcoin invented in secret
it was a gift to the world it's not just
the currency
but it's actually programmable money a
potential curse on bankers
and there's nothing that the the big
banks or politicians can do to stop it
breaking every government's grip on
money supply
what the internet did for information
bitcoin is doing for money
could it be the new gold no you have to
really
stretch your imagination to infer what
the intrinsic value of bitcoin is
regulators the federal reserve the
banking system at least understand this
is a
thing that they have to take seriously
this is going to change the economic
culture
bitcoin could be a micro economic
miracle worker
and it could be a macroeconomic wrecking
ball
is bitcoin the currency of the future
a godsend for criminals or a recipe for
financial disaster
if you trust your money just as it is
we have a little story to share
once upon a time there was a big party
with everyone standing around the punch
bowl
drunk
politicians credited the strong economy
to their wise decisions
businesses jumped into new profitable
markets ignoring risk
in fact the experts said there was no
risk
then troubling market data from minor
countries spooked the markets
rumors spread more bad news rattled
housing prices at the heart of the
financial world a major bank went
insolvent
investors and businesses made a run on
the other banks demanding their cash
deposits
the largest financial institutions in
the center of the modern world
were frozen assets were seized
banks foreclosed a credit crunch
threatened the entire world economy
[Music]
and then finally the government stepped
in
the largest bank bailout ever swift
action by the head of state had saved
the day
remember that no you don't
it happened two thousand years ago
rome 33 a.d ground zero for the first
recorded liquidity crisis and government
bailout in history the largest empire
the world had ever seen
was brought to its knees by a banking
disaster
emperor tiberius used money from the
national treasury
to bail out the country's troubled banks
and companies
history may not repeat itself but it
certainly rhymes
badly people in power
and their money have always been at the
very center of it
the story of money is as old as
civilization itself
when we lived in small tribes keeping
track of debt was easy
you owed somebody a load of firewood a
neighbor owed you a piece of meat
credits and debits were kept in your
head a mental ledger
currency is a language that allows us to
express transactional value between
people
it's a technology that's older than the
wheel
it's as old as fire
when humans wanted to trade outside
their tribe or village
they needed something everyone could
agree had value
something scalable enter commodity
monies
[Music]
there were many kinds but each had to
embody the same
five characteristics a commodity money
is relatively scarce
easily recognizable can be cut into
smaller pieces
you can substitute one piece for another
of equal value
and you can carry it around without too
much trouble
in ancient rome it was salt the aztecs
used cacao beans
it was whale teeth on fiji yak dung
in tibet shells in africa and china
grains metal ivory rare stones
leather fish if it had the five
characteristics of commodity money
someone probably used it as currency
and then you ask what value do these
currencies have
if you go into a primary school you'll
see children exchanging rubber bands and
tamagotchi and pokemon cards and
baseball cards and sweets
and candy and any other form of currency
people invent currency when they have no
other currency and now they're going to
invent digital currencies
but commodities that aren't durable are
a lousy store of value
a bad cacao crop or a huge new salt
discovery can throw your currency
and economy into turmoil a more stable
system was needed
about 2500 years ago the first metal
coins were minted in china
and in what is now turkey
these coins shared the same five
characteristics with commodity money
but were also very durable
in some cases coins are the only thing
left
of entire civilizations
money does not originate with
governments
money arises naturally
as markets begin to develop and as
people
with a division of labor realized that
if i have eggs
and you have a cow we may need some
medium of exchange
in order for you to buy my eggs for me
to buy your cow
coins were an objective and universal
unit of account
and they allowed people to buy and sell
goods over vast
regions the market economy was born
coins worked but only if people trusted
that the king or emperor who issued them
wasn't cheating on the metal content
using coins also meant that an authority
now controlled the supply of your
currency
money and political power were
inextricably linked
centralized minting coins in a steady
and predictable manner
allowed economic growth and stability
the wushu coin in china retained its
value for 500 years
in constantinople the solidus lasted for
700 years
but in those times the coins didn't have
the the milled
this sort of milled edge they were flat
and
what used to happen was as coins were
passing from people to people
people would cut little bits off and in
fact
some of the taxation that the kings
would do would actually be take
one-eighth of the coin off taxes built
castles
and financed military campaigns
expensive hobbies
soon royal mints were substituting
cheaper metals for silver and gold
this is called debasement and europe's
kings made a habit of it the currency of
france was debased every 20 months
for 200 years if no one can trust
the gold or silver content of your coins
how can you trade with other countries
international merchants found a solution
they recognize that
one person's debt has value it can be
traded or transferred
when those ious came from reputable
sources they could be used as a form of
money
paper money this money was not based on
hard commodities or metal but instead on
someone's promise to pay
merchant families like the medici in
15th century florence acted as
clearinghouses for these ious
it worked like this an english trader
ordered a shipment of italian cloth from
the medici for 100 gold coins
his promise to pay the medici was put on
paper meanwhile the medici owed 100 gold
coins to another trading partner
for delivery of wine from france the
parties didn't go to the expense of
transporting and exchanging gold coins
instead the paper was transferred
everyone agreed that the paper had value
100 gold coins but only because everyone
trusted the medici
as solvent middlemen they had created a
paper
money machine within a few generations
they rose from low crime
to high finance their great wealth
helped fuel the italian renaissance
and elevated the family to levels of
enormous political power
the power to marry into royal families
and get elected as popes
the ties binding money to power politics
and
influence now ran through church and
state
merchants had proven that creating paper
currency
could be wildly profitable goldsmiths
wanted in on the action
imagine it like this if the goldsmith
had seen over a period of time that
some of the coins he was storing for
people were gathering dust
the people who owned them don't need
them right now
so what if i go and lend them out into
the community
and i charge some interest on this loan
so he starts out lending some of these
gold coins and then
later he realizes actually people don't
even want the gold coins they just want
the piece of paper
that says the the gold coins are in the
bank and with the goldsmith
so i can now make a loan with these
pieces of paper
and whatever i write on a piece of paper
as long as people trust me
they'll trust the paper and effectively
the the goldsmiths
and the early day bankers they had
literally acquired
the power to print money more and more
private paper money from merchants and
banks circulated and began to rival the
crown's coins
the power inherent in controlling and
issuing money
began slipping away from the rulers they
couldn't tax or debase
this new kind of money but they had
bigger ambitions than ever with trading
posts colonies and
empires that now stretched across the
globe
for centuries european countries would
take turns building massive fleets and
waging war on each other to rule the
[Applause]
world
government wanted to take the people's
money in order to finance its wars
that's essentially the history of money
money and warfare go together
war is expensive one year's income taxes
simply aren't enough kings and queens
had to borrow money against future taxes
they needed a groundbreaking financial
innovation
government bonds the loans came from
rich merchant families and goldsmiths
who by now had become powerful
financiers and bankers
sovereign debt and deficit spending had
been born
[Music]
in 1694 the bank of england was
established to fund a war against france
england's central bank was privately
owned and granted the monopoly to issue
banknotes
paper that could be redeemed for an
equal amount of gold from the government
coffers
the central bank soon also managed the
entire debt of the crown
money has been a tool of sovereignty for
centuries being able to issue currency
gave you the power but it also gave the
value to that monetary supply
by backing it with the force of state
with
essentially the debt of state
[Music]
when the u.s won independence from
britain the first article of the new
constitution
gave congress the exclusive right to
coin money
this currency's value was tied to gold
in government vaults
from 1781 until the panic of 1907
the financial system of the us was an
economic petri dish
brief central banks state banks private
banks
private currency government currency
depressions
strong growth recessions regular boom
and bus
cycles the long term as far as capital
is concerned people want predictability
people want stability from the back of
that they can plan
now it's very hard to plan in the long
term with such a level of volatility
in 1913 bankers and politicians decided
that it was in the country's best
interest and theirs to have a permanent
central bank
they created the federal reserve among
its jobs
expand or contract the supply of a
single national currency
the federal reserve note the dollar was
tied to gold
and strategic control of it would avoid
booms that lead to busts
at least that was the plan
then came 1929
the great depression would have a
profound effect on monetary policy
worldwide i shall ask the congress for
the one remaining instrument
to meet the crisis fraud
executive power soon the fed had printed
nearly all the money it legally could to
pump life back
into the economy it needed gold to fire
up the mint
so in 1933 president roosevelt issued a
controversial
executive order forcing all u.s citizens
to sell their gold to the federal
reserve
at a fixed price or go to prison
the fed offered far more cash to foreign
governments for their gold
many jumped at the offer gold flowed in
and dollars spread across the globe
[Music]
world war ii devastated nearly every
major economy
except the united states
the military and industrial juggernaut
emerged as the
global financial superpower the dollar
had become the world's most stable and
trusted currency
other countries pegged their currency to
the dollar which could still be redeemed
for gold
in fact the u.s owned more than half of
the world's gold reserves
[Music]
in the next few decades more dollars
flowed to foreign countries
governments began debasing their coins
with cheaper metals
and printing more of their own currency
than they had in gold
the bond between precious metals and
paper currency was cracking
this is a 1966 50 cent piece it was the
last
coin in regular circulation in australia
to contain silver
it contains 80 silver so in 1966
this was 50 cents nowadays it's eight
dollars
roughly in silver alone by 1966
foreign nations had had enough of the
u.s collecting gold and printing cash
and they had more value in dollars than
the us had bullion in its vaults
they demanded gold in return for their
paper dollars
arguments about the value of the dollar
versus their currency ensued
in 1971 president nixon settled the
matter
he severed united states currency from
the gold standard
i have directed secretary connelly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar
in the gold or other reserve assets
except in amounts and conditions
determined to be in the interest of
monetary stability
and in the best interest of the united
states never again could anyone legally
demand
u.s government gold in exchange for
paper dollars
for better or worse the dollar was now
backed solely by the full
faith and credit of the united states
government
the wealthiest nation the world had ever
known would bet its future on a single
word trust
people have this mythology of money that
is based on very little fact
uh and one of the nice things about
bitcoin is that it forces
people to start to ask questions about
the fundamentals of money
bitcoin is an attempt uh to adopt
the advanced computerized system that we
have
the internet to resurrecting what money
used to be all about
[Music]
i think our dollar policies our monetary
policies our fiscal policies have
absolutely created a nation of debtors
not just personal debt not just
corporate debt but government debt you
have to look at those all together as
one big thing
what is the wealth of the nation well
the wealth of the nation is a gigantic
hole of money that we owe to the rest of
the world
that is never going to be paid back
today the united states pays more than
400 billion dollars in
interest to its creditors every year
when a government spends more money than
it collects in taxes
it simply borrows more or it creates
more
at one time every piece of paper money
was backed by gold
remember for every twenty dollar bill
there was twenty dollars worth of gold
in the government vault
not anymore today governments create
currency
by first creating bonds or treasury
bills
these bonds are sold in the market
generating funds for the government that
issued them
large banks buy us bonds to flip them
selling them to the federal reserve at a
profit
this is the magic money machine you see
the fed
is america's central bank but it doesn't
have any money
no cash on its balance sheets when a
bank buys a bond and takes it to the
federal reserve
the fed simply says thank you mr banker
here's the principle and some profit
new money isn't exchanged it simply
appears on the bank's accounts
magic for 100 years and counting the
precise mechanisms of these bond
purchases
have remained a secret
where it gets really interesting the
federal reserve is not a government
agency
it's a private entity and its
shareholders are banks which earn a
dividend as much as 80 billion dollars
per year total are paid out to some of
the very same banks
that sell the government debt to the fed
which banks don't even bother asking
that's also a secret
in other words the magic money machine
answers to no one
the fed also sets the bar for how much
interest you pay for a car
home or business loan the federal
reserve has been given
the impossible task of trying to run
the credit and monetary system as though
we are the soviet union
it's the central planner for the for the
key
aspect of capitalism which is how money
and credit is allocated the federal
reserve on balance uh does not help the
economy
on balance it hurts the economy and it's
bound to make
mistakes even with the best of
intentions
the fed is also supposed to boost
employment with low interest rates
encouraging people and businesses to buy
more goods and services
governments getting involved in money is
a good thing
and it's also a bad thing it's a good
thing because
money is the arteries of the economy the
blood supply of the economy
markets are subject to
bouts of euphoria and despair and
it makes sense for governments to
back currency and manipulate it moving
the money supply up and down
is the most powerful way to sedate
that boom and bust cycle
manipulating the supply of money has
short-term
and long-term consequences
[Music]
central banks aim to create new money
carefully
strategically and very very slowly
releasing more money into the economy
causes prices to rise
ideally by two percent every year that's
supposed to foster economic growth
but two percent inflation means the
buying power of one
cash dollar in your pocket today will be
98 cents
next year and less nearly every year to
come
since 1913 when the federal reserve took
over the united states dollar
we've seen that the united states dollar
has decreased in value 98
inflation is a far higher tax because on
your income you pay it just once
if inflation is 2 you're paying a 2 tax
on your net worth
every single year your net worth held in
currency
so what does that mean
if you earned a dollar in 1913 you could
buy 16 loaves of bread
today a dollar barely buys you one
that's not a quaint notion of how cheap
things used to be
it's proof that the value of your cash
is slowly withering away
that one dollar invested at two percent
in 1913
would now be worth seven dollars and 24
cents
more than 600 percent return versus a
near
total loss the us dollar has gone
from being worth one dollar to now being
worth about
four cents uh so that's you know 96
of its original value and it's a direct
result of government control
governments don't create money from thin
air all alone
you play a key role in the magic money
machine
it's not really the central banks that
are the problem and they're part of the
problem but the real problem is that
we've given the power to create money
to the same banks that caused the
financial crisis
we put our paychecks and savings into a
bank account and draw from it as we need
it
the banks are custodians of our money
right
wrong it is now the property of the bank
on their balance sheets they can do just
about
anything they want with it for example
create new money
here's how your bank account shows 100
but the bank only holds three and loans
97 to bob
to buy something in the bank's computers
you still have 100
in your account but bob now has 97
of new virtual money in his account just
digits on a computer screen
there's no cash no gold or anything else
backing up the new numbers in bob's
account
just his promise to pay it back
this is new money created as debt
when those 97 are spent say in a shop
the shop owner deposits into another
bank and it is let out again
and again and again and each of these
people
have numbers in their accounts showing
that they own
this money so your original one hundred
dollars has multiplied
now there are over three thousand three
hundred dollars in the system
this process of loaning out far more
money than a bank actually has
as cash on hand is called fractional
reserve
banking in the uk 97
of the money that exists is just numbers
in the computer system
and those numbers are created by the
banks
banks earn untold billions in interest
every year by creating and lending
virtual money
what's more banks don't even need your
deposit to create new money
if they consider someone credit worthy
for a loan
they can put new magic money into his or
her account
and start charging interest so reporters
talk about bitcoin as though it's a as
though it's the first digital currency
but actually we use digital currency
every time you make a transaction
through internet banking or through your
your bank card actually it's not even
just digital currency it's digital
currency that is created by
the banks essentially i have nothing in
other words
all new money is debt this is the part
of money creation that isn't taught in
economics class
money in paychecks bank accounts 401ks
that loan to bob credit card debt your
home loan
all began life as virtual money created
by the banks
the entire system is based on trust
trust in the bank's solvency
trust in the debtor's ability to repay
their debt
if all bank customers demanded just
three percent of their deposits right
now
in cash this run on the banks would
reveal the truth
almost none of that paper currency you
think is in your bank account exists
it never did
remember the drunken party
our financial crisis had everything to
do with virtual dollars
too many people with very little income
borrowed a lot of money they could never
repay
but the banks didn't care they didn't
have to
they quickly made and sold shaky loans
to someone else for a profit
and i got them all approved hey fly now
selling bad loans was a good business
until the whole thing blew up in the
global financial crisis
the magic money machine destroyed 30
million real
jobs
the united states alone lost 16 trillion
dollars
in household wealth and the banks
foreclosed on more than one million
homes
[Music]
selling subprime loans and betting they
will fail
may not be sacred but it is lucrative
as much as one quarter of our best and
brightest are being lured by the siren
call
of the money machine instead of science
engineering or medicine they chose a
career playing with
betting with other people's money to get
rich
quick very rich and sometimes
they take shortcuts
[Music]
my ancestors in greece talked about the
corrupting influence of power
and nothing has changed in these 3 000
years
when you give control over massive
amounts of money to a few individuals
they will take advantage of that control
banks today are factoring in fines and
money laundering and all the rules that
they break into their cost of doing
business
jp morgan is today coming out and saying
that bitcoin is
not a legitimate way of doing business
banks today are tied into a system
that is completely rigged to basically
harvest money from the entire
global economy and pump it into the
hands of very few
[Music]
the existing banking system is cozy it's
captured the regulators
it extracts enormous value from society
without delivering anything in return
and it is parasitic in nature
the banks play a very pivotal role in an
economy you look at any successful
economy it has successful banks there's
a very close correlation with banking
profits and the economy as a whole
in medieval europe a banker who couldn't
repay depositors
was hanged today that same banker would
get
bailed out paid bonuses and enjoy some
tax benefits too
to date no senior u.s banking executive
has been charged for selling the bad
loans that fueled
the great recession
in december 2014 just six years
after the last banking crisis brought
the world to its knees
a congressman snuck a last-minute
provision written by citigroup
into a crucial funding bill the
provision allows the largest
u.s banks to once again make risky
derivatives
bets with bank deposits
but no need to worry if the banks
implode again
lost deposits must be paid back
by u.s taxpayers
today's financial innovators package
assets in
ever more complex ways slicing dicing
securitizing always using someone else's
money
they sell debt transfer risks leverage
bets that's what they call innovation
when you're talking about financial
innovation bitcoin certainly uh is
is a very good example of innovation but
there's also been other innovations that
people
a bit closer to the world of finance
would
cite as good examples an example of that
would be the original swaps market
from there moving on to the credit
default swap it is an
excellent example of financial
innovation but also
if it's used incorrectly it can create a
lot of problems as we've just seen
history teaches that the most
revolutionary and disruptive innovation
nearly always comes from the fringe not
from corporate cubicles
true innovators see the world
differently they see the big picture
creating new products and entire systems
that lead to new industries
steve jobs called them the square cogs
in round holes
it's unsurprising that new innovations
always come from
a niche group of early adopters because
it is inherently
very hard for many people to realize the
benefits of new technologies
in 2011 most bitcoin community people
were
either people from the technology space
the geeks and
hackers or people from the traditional
financial industry there are even some
bankers and
hedge fund traders using bikonika at
that time as well which was
really surprising to me
a radical new idea is often met with
skepticism
ridicule even hostility from those who
stand to lose the most
from its success case in point
the automobile
in the late 19th century carl benz and
others built the first
cars contraptions that could threaten
the stagecoach
and railroad industries these
self-propelled vehicles or
road trains would certainly scare horses
injure people and damage roads cars
the railroad barons said were just too
dangerous
and to protect us they used their power
to pass a law
in 1865 it required every automobile in
england to observe a four mile per hour
speed limit
and to be operated by a crew of three
a driver an engineer and a flag man
this heroic flagmen walked in front of
the car to warn fellow citizens
of the coming danger the railroad
tycoons the lawmakers the self-appointed
gatekeepers
used regulation to stifle innovation
but they didn't invent the flagman he's
been around for a long time
for centuries very few could read books
were copied by hand
the people in control political and
religious leaders
wanted to keep it that way and they
greeted johann gutenberg's printing
press
with licensing laws publishing bans
taxes in some parts of the world
printing was a crime
punishable by death after all they were
just protecting us from dangerous ideas
before the printing press there were an
estimated 30 000
books in all of europe 50 years later
there were 10 million as gutenberg's
invention flourished the dark ages
withered
progress couldn't be stopped but the
flag man never stops trying
his master set him loose on each of
these innovations
because they threatened someone's
profits someone's control
[Music]
but remember this is a story about money
what if a technological innovation
allowed anyone in the world
to be their own bank to create a
currency
free from taxes and banking fees
the u.s constitution forbids citizens
from printing or minting their own
currency
competing with or undercutting reliance
on the u.s dollar
in 1998 bernard von notthaus decided to
test the resolve
of the federal government the liberty
dollar was available in gold
silver platinum and copper it was
available in three forms
both in specie in other words gold and
silver
in paper as warehouse recedes and in
digital form
obviously the government didn't like it
they
arrested me and convicted me
of counterfeiting fraud and conspiracy
and i'm currently awaiting
22 years sentence in federal prison
[Music]
lesson learned at a hacker's
convention in another one there was a
young
hacker there who used the alias
of satoshi nakamoto
and he talked to a friend of mine and he
identified
the liberty dollar and me as inspiring
him to create a new currency
bernard von notthaus's arrest for
creating private money
may also have inspired bitcoin's
inventor to keep a lower profile
publishing the invention under an alias
and vanishing part of me is interested
to know
like who satoshi is maybe that's part of
the mystique
of the story it's completely irrelevant
to the functioning of bitcoin because we
have the
the code to read but it would be kind of
fun to know
who is archimedes
who is euclid
we don't know we don't know if euclid
was one person or multiple people
and you know what it doesn't matter
euclidean geometry
works whether i know who euclid was or
not
whether euclid was a moral and good
person
or whether he was a corrupt plutocrat
and a bastard
science and mathematics have essential
truth that stands alone irrespective of
its inventors and irrespective of their
motives
well bitcoin is a system based on
mathematical truths
and these mathematical truths stand
alone we can read the source code in
bitcoin and understand it
and it will be true whether satoshi
nakamoto is a man
a woman a collection of individuals a
government agency
or aliens from the future
bitcoin is digital currency and computer
software
capital b bitcoin is the shared code
that creates a global payment network
using computers connected to the
internet
bitcoins are virtual currency digital
money created
stored and exchanged on that network
but unlike virtual dollars created by a
banker this new currency was created
with math
by an anonymous inventor bitcoin
is an open source software protocol like
much of the code supporting the internet
and email open source means
anyone everyone can use the protocol no
one person or company can control it
every change to the software is public
open
and transparent the code was first
developed by satoshi
then there were dozens now hundreds of
programmers
constantly collaborating to improve
bitcoin's features and security
so what makes bitcoin a breakthrough it
tackles an
ancient human dilemma and solves a
computer science problem
any shared information or data can be
flawed
corrupted anything can be faked
how do we know that what we're receiving
can be trusted
in our traditional mindset it's very
important to know who is behind this
currency
because their reputation is significant
in knowing that our funds and the true
wealth
is actually safe in finance we rely on
trusted third parties
like banks credit card companies
remittance services
they keep track of money as it moves
from one account to another
and they charge us handsomely for it we
trust that their digital ledgers of
credits and debits
balance a financial system that cuts out
these middlemen
could be faster cheaper and more secure
but bitcoin is digital music and movies
are easily pirated
copied stolen how can a digital currency
retain value
if anyone can make a million copies the
answer is at the core of satoshi's
invention
a bitcoin is not a file on a computer
it's an entry in the publicly
distributed database called the
blockchain
just as the medici kept a ledger of
credits and debits
today's banks record each transaction as
a plus and minus in their ledgers
now we call them databases bank accounts
are replaced by a digital wallet that
you alone controlled
bitcoin's ledger is the blockchain a
record of every bitcoin in existence
and every bitcoin transaction ever made
it always balances
because no bitcoin ever leaves it
when a bitcoin is sent from one digital
wallet to another
what they are really sending is control
over that part of the database
code that is a unique key for the new
owner
as the network processes transactions it
constantly synchronizes the one ledger
across the global network each computer
or bitcoin miner
has a complete and identical copy
and because the blockchain is public it
cannot be controlled by any one person
or computer
owners of the bitcoin mining computers
are rewarded with new bitcoins for
processing transactions and keeping the
network secure
[Music]
in other words the bitcoin network
replaces banks and bankers
today the combined computing power of
this global network
is greater than the 500 biggest super
computers combined
times 10 000 and because every
transaction
is verified and recorded by the network
a bitcoin cannot be forged
digital currency cannot be debased with
cheap metals or printed by the billion
at will
too much currency can unleash a monster
skyrocketing prices trillion dollar
bills that can't buy a loaf of bread
there's a big movement in the us
demanding that the fed
be audited so we can find out what
they're doing
nobody really knows how many dollars are
in existence for example
ben bernanke created several trillions
of dollars over the last several years
but nobody really knows where they
landed at any time for any reason the
central banks can print as much money as
they want
they call it fancy things like
quantitative easing and when they do
that it makes the dollars or euros or
yen that you and i have worth less
so if the world starts using bitcoin as
their their currency
it can't be controlled by central
bankers or politicians
remember central banks create money to
boost the economy
and try to pull it back out before
inflation heats up
but no one knows how much magic money
global banks are creating to boost their
profits with questionable loans
bitcoin is completely the opposite it's
totally transparent you know exactly how
many exists
the computer code behind bitcoin has a
built-in brake pedal
cutting the creation of bitcoins in half
every four years
this ensures a transparent controlled
scarcity
and ultimately limits the total number
of bitcoins to 21 million
no lobbyist no politician no banker can
create more
or change the mathematical rules
dictating their creation
advancing accountability uh and that's
something i think is most exciting about
bitcoin and the technology behind it
is not so much that it will supplant the
dollar or that it will supplant
government itself but that all of a
sudden there's a competitor to
government and the government itself
now needs to look over its shoulder more
than it did
this new digital currency can be
purchased online with a credit card
or in person with cash and it has the
five
key characteristics of money but is it a
store
of value is it stable or will it
diminish
over time like a commodity rented
useless
or a crop that fails the ultimate power
of a cryptocurrency is unleashed by
mainstream adoption
and an ever-growing volume of
transactions
with bitcoin the currency has been
created much
more slowly than other currencies and
the effect of that has been to turn it
into what is essentially a speculative
asset
if you ask a lot of bitcoin enthusiasts
whether they're
spending the currency they're not
they're sitting on it and waiting for
the price to go up
it isn't a currency if you don't use it
to pay people
the point is the average person is quite
happy to walk into a bar
and hand over you know a five dollar
note in order to get
a drink so you've got to realize that
most people are happy with
the money system they have if most
people are happy with cash
they're in love with plastic in the u.s
two-thirds of in-person sales are done
with debit or credit cards
that plastic is a 60 year old technology
created by a middleman never designed
for the internet
each transaction requires personal data
like your name
and address credit card databases are
regularly hacked
with fraudulent purchases charged to
your account
criminals buy and sell stolen credit
cards by the thousands
in dark corners of the internet in some
parts of london
one third of all online credit card
transactions are fraudulent
card issuers don't hold you responsible
for fraud
but protection comes with a price two to
four percent in fees
that's 50 billion dollars a year the
issue with credit cards
from a merchant's perspective is there's
a lot of risk if they take a credit card
there might be a chargeback there might
be fraudulent
purchases in fact there's hundreds of
billions of dollars every year
in fraudulent purchases a bitcoin
purchase
is done for pennies but there are no
protections if you lose your passwords
or are fooled into paying the wrong
person you can never get your money back
it is like digital cash for a seller
this means no
chargeback risks for an e-commerce
company like expedia or overstock
cutting credit card fees can double
their profit margin
[Music]
you could not miss the point more
effectively
than by thinking of bitcoin as a
currency and payment network
that will make shopping easier for the
first world bitcoin
is about everything else everywhere else
there are 2.5 billion people without a
bank account
with bitcoin a mobile phone with an
internet connection
is now a bank with access to the global
marketplace
what happens when bitcoin services and
infrastructure and bitcoin wallets and
payment processes
start going into these countries these
people will be able to
gain benefits from trade where they
could not previously
these people will be able to send money
home
uh international remittance which is one
of the major pain points of the current
financial system
here if i send a hundred dollars with
banks going to cost me 20 percent
western union is going to cost 10
percent uh other options that are
competing western union still going to
be about 5
and if you are sending to really remote
areas it's going to be anywhere between
15
and 30 percent
so in terms of money movement says it's
going to be a game changer
using bitcoin you do not need a bank
account you just need an internet
connection and a
wallet to get set up it's a tool to give
people an access into the global
ecosystem and give them a promise for an
economic future
and specifically provide a way for them
to not be dependent
on a government that could shut down
their bank accounts or even could go
into their bank accounts and take out
finances
goldman sachs came out with a report and
they basically looked at if you were to
replace
all transactions globally so fx bank to
bank
transactions with the bitcoin protocol
and still charging one percent mind you
it would save the global economy
200 billion so not million 200 billion
dollars a year
in saved transaction costs which
ultimately goes back into the hands
of the consumer an international wire
transfer can take up to four days yet
the internet allows us to instantly and
globally share
text pictures videos anything digital
why not money money which we now know
only exists as
digits in a bank's database wouldn't it
be great if you could
send bitcoin transactions just simply
via tweet
for example you would say at the end of
money
one dollar worth of bitcoin and so we
built just that all you have to do is
hashtag it with tippercoin
press send and our twitter bot will
process the transactions notify you and
give you a link
and this will allow you to either
withdraw your bitcoins or send it to
someone else
with bitcoin you can send one dollar or
one million dollars worth of value
anywhere in the world
you can do it for free or you pay the
bitcoin network fee which is still just
around a penny and there's
nothing that the big banks or
politicians can do to stop it
a cryptocurrency that can only be
created and transferred with computer
networks
may be the next step of the digital
revolution
the rise of machines self-driving cars
drones robots that rely less and less
on humans what i
often think is that the future of
bitcoin or digital currency
from you know a broader perspective is
really about machine to machine payments
so by the time you have an unmanned taxi
driving you around new york
and then going to power up at an
unmanned power station
or going to get repairs at an unmanned
auto shop
you'll see the machine to machine
payments done with some sort of digital
currency
[Music]
[Music]
we actually built this world that we
live in over the last two or three
hundred years we've made some mistakes
we've learned to make things better
the idea that there's some magic key
that if you just sort of stop doing a
few things that there'll be this perfect
order that will settle is a very
childish ideological delusion
in my opinion but that is not to say
that bitcoin isn't an exciting thing
it's a terrifically exciting thing
but we have to try and engage with it
with working minds not with magical
thinking
people are suggesting that it's going to
be
another world currency rivalry in the
dollar or the euro or the yen
i think that's not going to happen
i prefer to trust the banks or the
central government compared to the
bitcoin
is because someone's accountable whereas
with the bitcoin it's completely
deregulated
there's no central control there's no
one held accountable
it is a free float it's purely demand
and supply driven
so clearly this is not a currency
currencies don't behave like this but
what this
is is a high risk speculative commodity
so for the entrepreneurs the bankers the
governments and everyone else studying
and watching bitcoin
all i have to say is that there will
probably be a lot of volatility in an
upward trajectory
and to buckle up
criminals scam artists bad actors are
drawn to
any kind of money like a moth to a flame
silk road was a marketplace that was
online it existed in the underground web
now this marketplace allowed people to
sell things that were illegal to
governments
fake ids pirated music
bibles in north korea are crypto
currencies inherently bad
or just the newest tool to acquire the
forbidden
porn is illegal in iran it was a few
percent percentage points of sales on
silk road was to sell porn to iranians
now a much broader one that gets a lot
of press with regards to silk road
is drugs
i've been doing research over the past
couple of years into the
online drug marketplaces in the darknet
using tor and bitcoin
as technologies to enable illicit drug
transactions
we did a global survey of drug users
and we had over 20 000 people respond to
that
and the majority of those people were
buying
traditionally illicit drugs ecstasy
cannabis
the fbi brought down silk road it
certainly hasn't
stopped the trading of illicit drugs
online
a lot of people want to criticize
bitcoin for being used for
for illegal things or a list of things
but if you look at it the most popular
currency in the entire world for doing
bad things
is the us dollar
if you think of bitcoin as a platform
instead of a currency
then you really begin to see the
potential it has
the ledger which cannot be forged it
cannot be changed and the universe
accepted
is genius there will be bitcoin
technology forever
and it'll have applications for years to
come creating a secure
global payment system may just be the
beginning
patents contracts land titles proof of
ownership can be baked into bitcoin
securely held in the public ledger
i read up more about bitcoin i played
with the source code
i built some things that i realized this
is actually a very very powerful
protocol it's not just the currency but
it's actually programmable money
the digital age has fundamentally
changed the world
we have embraced digitized music film
medical records communications the
internet
the free exchange of information and
currency can
fuel revolutions help in a disaster
but our money is shackled to the 20th
century
manipulated by governments and banks
the champions of bitcoin ask us to
imagine
payments without a middleman investments
without a broker
loans without a bank insurance without
an underwriter
charity without a trustee escrow without
an
agent betting without a bookie record
keeping without an accountant
global secure nearly instant
and free is it fantasy or the future of
money and commerce
i love bitcoins i'm really into bitcoin
well satoshi nakamoto
that's the name i love to say and we
don't know much about him
but he came to save the day if you don't
know what a bitcoin is
right usually the way people describe it
is uh digital cash
it's money for the internet of bitcoin
as you're going into the old blockchain
of bitcoin i know you're going to rain
gonna rain
people are like oh i love my bank i'm
like really you ask a banker you know
what's two plus two he's like well i can
tell you but there's a fee
down the road it will be told about the
death of old mount gox
about traders trading alter coins and
miners mining
now bitcoin is a new technology i like
to say
it's banking lights all of the
[Music]
convenience know you're going to rain
gonna rain until everybody knows
everybody knows
you know when i go online and i buy like
i don't know a pair of socks
if i pay with a credit card i'm just
buying socks
right if i buy those socks with bitcoin
it's a revolution
i am sticking it to the man
lord pass me some more
there's always people who are not ready
to get into the new technology
you know like when the internet came out
there was people going nah
i don't think this is gonna be popular
and then email came out and people like
nah
this isn't gonna catch on and now
bitcoin comes out people like
i don't think i'm like aren't you sick
of being wrong
get on this train you know